اشهر تسعه مرت على الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا انهكت الطرفين بشكل واضح وافرغت
مخازن السلاح كما يبدو وحتى العزم الغربي
على مدكرانيا بالسلاح وفقا نيويورك
والتناسب بين استهلاك الذخيره وانتاجها
باتاكسيا الغرب لم يعد قادرا على الحفاظ
على الخط البياني للتغذيه العسكريه في
ارتفاع او حتى ثبت المخازن تفرغ بينما
روسيا واوكرانيا تحرقان الاسلحه بوتيره لم
يسبق لها مثيل منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه
ليرتبط مصير الحرب بالحفاظ على استمراريه
تدفق السلاح للطرفين
عدد الطلقات في اليوم الواحد في اوكرانيا
يعادل شهرا او اكثر في افغانستان تصريح
ات ما اطلقتها الولايات المتحده تصر على
ان مخزوناتها تسد الحاجه الاوكرانيه
الملحه في سبيل الحمايه مصلحه في كل مكان
نحن ملتزمون بتزويد اوكرانيا بما تحتاجه
في ساحه المعركه
اكثر اقترحها الغرب على دول اوروبا
الشرقيه كالعوده لمعدتي الحقبه سوريا
كامظلمه
واستثمار مصانع الاسلحه القديمه لاعاده
تصنيع الذخائر
روسيا ليست في حال افضل فهي ايضا تقتصد في
استهلاك الذخائر وتزيد الانتاج العسكري
رغم ذلك تتجه نحو حليفتيها لشراء الصواريخ
من كوريا الشماليه واستخدام المسيرات
الايرانيه الرخيصه الى عمر العربيه